it doesn't seem to make sense to suggest
that there might be such a thing as good
materialism after all isn't materialism
just plain bad always it can seem as if
we're faced with a stark choice either
you can be materialistic and that means
obsessed with money and possessions
shallow and selfish or you can reject
materialism be good and focus on more
important matters of the Spirit but in
truth most of us are in our hearts stuck
somewhere between these two choices
which is pretty uncomfortable we're
still in meshed in the desire to possess
but we're encouraged to feel rather bad
about it yet crucially it's not actually
materialism the pure fact of buying
things and getting excited by
possessions that ever really the problem
with failing to make a clear distinction
between good and bad versions of
materialism let's try to understand good
materialism through a slightly
unintuitive
religion because we see them as focused
exclusively on spiritual things it can
be surprising to note how much use
religions have made of material things
they spent a lot of time making and
thinking about Scrolls to hang in your
house shrines temples monasteries
artworks clothes ceremonies however
they've cared about these things for one
reason only because they've wanted
material things to serve the highest and
noblest purpose the development of our
souls it's just that they've recognized
that we are incarnate sensory bodily
beings and that the way to get through
to our souls has to be at least in part
through our bodies rather than merely
through the intellect the importance of
material things was for centuries at the
core of Christianity which proposed that
Jesus with both the highest spiritual
being and a flashing blood person he was
the spirit incarnate holiness embodied
in the Catholic Mass great significance
is accorded to the bread and wine which
are believed to be transubstantiation of
Christ that is material objects which
simultaneously have a spiritual identity
just as Jesus himself combined the
spiritual and the
oddly while on earth this can all sound
like a very weird and arcane point
entirely removed from the local shopping
mall but exactly the same concept
actually applies outside of religions
many good material possessions can be
said to involve a kind of
transubstantiation whereby they are both
practical and physical and also embody
or allude to a positive personality or
spirit take this watch by the designer
dieter Rams to the outer I it's an
ordinary timepiece but at a
psychological level it's also a kind of
transferred fancy ation it tells the
time but it also hints at a more
psychological even spiritual size with
ideals of purity simplicity and harmony
floating around it it tells us how long
there is to lunch but it's also trying
to nudge us towards being a certain sort
of person or take this chair it too can
substantiate a set of important values
straightforwardness strengths honesty
and elegance by getting closer to the
chair we stand to become a little more
like it which is an important piece of
inner evolution material objects can
therefore be said to play a positive
psychological or spiritual role in our
lives when higher more positive ideals
are materialized in them and so when
buying and using them daily gives us a
chance to get closer to our better
selves when they're contained in
physical things valuable psychological
qualities that are otherwise often
intermittent in our thoughts and conduct
can become more stable and resilient
this isn't to say that all consumerism
just conveniently turns out to be great
it depends on what a given material
object stands for an object can
transubstantiated sides of human nature
greed callousness the desire to triumph
as much as it can the best sides so we
must be careful not to decry or
celebrate all material consumption just
like that we have to ensure that the
objects we invest in and tire ourselves
and the planet by making are those that
lend most encouragement to our higher
better natures
you